why don't we see a decent number of
gray-haired software developers in the
industry
where do all the programmers go when
they become older
based on the github's annual survey data
which included responses from over 100
000 software developers
less than 15 percent of them were older
than 40 years old
in other words according to the largest
international poll data
the vast majority of the software
developers or over 85 percent of them
are in the range between 15 and 40 years
old
so why are there fewer senior developers
in the industry
first they expect higher salaries it's
obvious that an experienced and older
developer deserves and expects a higher
pay than a younger one
the problem however is the demand do the
software companies
need these experienced developers at any
cost maybe not
most companies don't need a lot of
highly experienced software engineers
it is simply not feasible to maintain a
lot of older developers with a higher
salary
second most developers find a way to
make more money without writing code
so switching job is another reason a lot
of senior developers move up in the
career ladder into managerial positions
where they become chief technology
officers head of products and vice
presidents of engineering
still others become consultants and
provide advisory services to other
technology companies and startups
some senior developers who work at top
top-tier tech companies such as google
and facebook
earn enough to retire early and pursue
their passion projects
including starting their youtube
channels
third no other professional in other
industries has to learn this much and
this fast
technology programming languages and
frameworks are changing so fast
that many developers can't keep up with
it just look at the javascript landscape
with age there are a lot of other
responsibilities that come to the older
generation
this is another reason why we see fewer
older programmers
fourth internal company environments
could be challenging for older
developers as time goes on
senior developers start to notice they
are on the older side of the team
and find themselves in a pool of younger
programmers
many can't connect with the younger
teammates because of the generation gap
and some other factors they might feel
lonely in the workplace
fifth the startup culture favors younger
developers
startup founders try to go fast and
break things
every entrepreneur's dream is to change
the world in some positive way
an idea is a fragile thing execution is
everything
but before the execution entrepreneurs
need some tech products
they can't afford to wait a long time
for a product to be built
because when an idea fails entrepreneurs
have to learn from the mistakes and
pivot into another direction
all these experiments require fast
development
so for cheap and fast product
development entrepreneurs
always look for younger software
engineers
older developers face concerns about the
stability of the roles they're in
which can lead to heightened stress this
can be avoided by taking early
preparation
the most important factor in staying
employed as a senior software developer
is to stay relevant
companies don't hire young programmers
because they're young
they hire them because their skills are
relevant
older programmers will have no problems
staying employed or finding new
engineering jobs if they decide to keep
their skills relevant
at all times keep up with programming
methodologies
and learn new technologies in other
words software developers who want to
stay in this profession for a long time
need to follow the unmind if you have a
young mind
whatever age you are will matter less
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell
enjoy the rest of your day